President Trump is doubling down on his
defense of Supreme Court justice Brett
Kavanaugh after the latest allegation of
sexual misconduct the president calls it
a smear while Democrats say the FBI
failed to check out that claim a year
ago before Kavanaugh was confirmed Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy have we
heard from Kavanaugh himself about this
Anthony Kavanaugh has not responded to
this new allegation though in the past
he has denied the other accusations
President Trump on the other hand not
staying quiet he is taking on a familiar
target the New York Times for publishing
and then adjusting this story I called
for the resignation of everybody at the
New York Times involved in the president
Trump defended the Supreme Court justice
he appointed against a new accusation of
sexual misconduct over the weekend the
New York Times published an excerpt from
a book written by two of its reporters
in it a classmate at Yale says he saw
Kavanagh exposed himself to a female
student at a party in the 1980s The
Times later issued a clarification
noting that the female student declined
to be interviewed for the book and
friends say that she does not recall the
incident we all remember this pattern
from last time around shoot first
rectify later Republicans slammed
Democrats calling for Cavanaugh's
impeachment this is not an allegation
it's barely a third-hand rumor but
Democrats are still questioning the
thoroughness of the FBI's background
investigation into Kavanagh it was a
sham Delaware Democrat Chris Kuhn said
he was aware of the Yale allegation
during the confirmation hearings and
wrote to the FBI asking it to
investigate the FBI did not thoroughly
investigate credible allegations and I
think it's important that we all know
why Massachusetts congresswoman diana
Presley is introducing an impeachment
inquiry resolution in
to Cavanaugh in the house today but it's
unlikely to go anywhere because the man
who would likely leave that inquiry
Judiciary Chairman Jerry Nadler says
he's already got his hands full Tony
with his impeachment inquiry into
President Trump
Nancy Cordes forced Nancy thank you very
much